[Music]
state management for whatever reason is
a topic that brings out strong opinions
and developers I'm gonna have to go
ahead and sort of disagree with you
there in today's video we'll look at 10
different ways to build a basic counter
app using different state management
strategies employer we'll also just talk
about what state management is and why
there are so many different ways to
approach it and hopefully by the end of
this video you know exactly where
strategy is ideal for your app if you're
new here like and subscribe and you grab
the full source code on fire ship IO and
I'm giving away another t-shirt with
this video just leave me a comment with
your own opinions about state management
below first of all what is stake in a
reactive framework like flutter you can
think of your UI as the return value of
a function that function gets called
with one argument which is your state so
state is just data that changes over the
lifecycle of your app a lot of your data
can be self-contained within a single
widget that's known as local state we'll
look at the tools that we have built
into flutter to manage local state which
is pretty straightforward things get
interesting when we start talking about
global state or state that needs to be
shared throughout the widget tree coming
from the web development world I've seen
tons of debate over state management and
a lot of apps over engineered with these
big state management libraries that
didn't really need them that's not to
say they're not valuable but even the
creators and maintainer of those
libraries will tell you that you
probably don't need them we'll talk
about the pros and cons of these various
libraries as we go but for now let's
focus on the fundamental building blocks
in flutter starting with the stateful
widget when you run flutter create from
the command line it gives you some
starter code that increments a counter
with a stateful widget we're going to
rebuild this counter multiple times
throughout this video using different
state management strategies to create a
stateful widget we need two classes the
first one is the stateful widget itself
and that implements a create state
method and that returns our second class
which is an extension of the state class
and this is where all the heavy lifting
happens first we define a property
called counter which is an integer that
defines the actual data state of this
widget then we define a method called
increment counter and it calls a method
called set state which will tell this
widget to re-render when this value
changes after that we implement the
build function which defines the actual
widgets that will be rebuilt every time
set state is called I've stripped these
down to the bare minimum
we just have a text widget that will
display the current value of the counter
and we have a floating action button
that will increment the counter when
pressed stateful widgets are great for
managing local state but there's a
couple things I don't like here first of
all we have to define two separate
classes which is sort of confusing and
adds boilerplate and I know from
experience with react j/s that coin set
state all over the place does not scale
very well it's fine when we just have
one property but you can imagine how
this would become a mess if we had 20
different properties on this widget to
update and with that I'll move on to
topic number two a stateful builder
there's a variety of different builder
widgets in flutter that allow you to
react to different types of changes one
of those a stateful builder which will
allow us to simplify our stateful widget
code notice this time we're starting by
extending a stateless widget and then
we'll define our state as a counter that
starts at zero then the first widget
that will add to our build method is a
stateful builder and that takes a
builder function that function gives us
access to the build context and also a
function called set state when we call
set state it will tell the stateful
builder to rebuild all the widgets
inside this function and they'll look
pretty much identical to the previous
example where we have text for the
counter value and then a floating action
button to increment it now I want to
point out that I'm kind of breaking the
rules in flutter that's why you see this
green squiggly line under the class name
this class is immutable which means the
properties on it should never be
reassigned and we're violating that by
incrementing the counter so if you use a
stateful builder within a stateless
widget I would recommend setting up your
data as a map or a list because you can
mutate values in those data structures
without breaking the contract of the
stateless widget but overall the
stateful builder is a nice little tool
that helps you avoid the boilerplate of
a stateful widget and is really ideal
when you have simple local state
management to deal with but now things
are going to start getting interesting
because we're going to talk about app
state or global state in flutter it's
possible to pass data from top to bottom
or from parent to child but it's not
really practical to pass data the other
way around from child back to parent or
from sibling to sibling but almost every
non-trivial app is going to have some
kind of shared state at one point or
another that runs into this limitation
the first thing I want to show you is
inherited widget now I don't recommend
using this as a state management
solution because there are better
alternatives that already do it for you
but it's important to know how it works
because it's a fundamental building
block in flutter that's implemented in
many other
features of the framework basically it's
a widget that allows you to pass context
to any of its descendants no matter how
far nested they are in the widget tree
so the first thing you'll usually do is
put the inherited widget towards the top
of the widget tree which we've done here
with our inherited counter and then we
have our actual homepage as a child of
that inherited widget our inherited
counter will extend the inherited widget
built into flutter and it will take a
child widget as an argument to its
constructor from there we're going to
override a method called update should
notify and this will run when this
inherited widget is rebuilt and will
notify any descendents whether or not
they need to rebuild I'm just setting it
to true but you could look at the
different the widget actually needs to
re-render
and then it's conventional to also
implement a static method called of
thing calls inherit from widget of exact
type with the inherited counter type now
the inherited widget is immutable so we
could wrap it in a stateful widget to
tell it when to rebuild but for the sake
of simplicity I'll just go ahead and
define our counter data as a map this is
a private variable so first we'll go
ahead and define an increment method
which allows us to increment the counter
value and then we'll add a getter to get
the current value from the map now that
we have that setup we can go down here
and define our state list widget home
page now just for convenience I'm using
the example we had set up previously
with our stateful builder and inside
that builder method we can access the
value from the inherited counter by
calling of context with the values from
that class now this may look trivial in
this example but if you imagine our
homepage was nested 20 levels deep it
could still access these values without
having to directly pass anything through
each constructor in the widget tree now
like I said earlier you probably don't
need to mess with inherited widgets
directly and you'll see why later in
this video because there's already
libraries that do similar things in a
much less awkward way but before we get
to that point I want to show you my
personal favorite way to manage global
State in a flutter app and that is to
leverage a special type of stream and rx
dart called a behavior subject we'll
start by creating our own custom class
and then give it a private value that's
set to a behavior subject that starts at
0 these are incredibly useful for state
management for a variety of reasons
first of all they always have a current
value that we can read and flutters
build methods but at the same time we
can treat them as a stream and a stream
that we can control by adding new values
to it and it's a broadcast stream by
default
so multiple widgets can listen to the
same stream this allows us to implement
our own business logic related to the
flow of data for the stream and we can
do it completely independent of the
widget tree that makes it much easier to
test in isolation and also just easier
to reason about now we can define our
own custom API that our widgets can
consume for example if we want to expose
the stream we can just call counter
stream then we can also create a getter
that grabs the current value
synchronously from the behavior subject
and then we'll define a method to mutate
the behavior subject called increment
which just adds a new value to the
stream and that's basically all it takes
to build your own custom state
management solution that all of your
widgets can react to and share now I'm
going to just instantiate it in the
global namespace which is kind of
frowned upon but I'll show you an
alternative to this in just a minute
now that we have access to this counter
service globally we can rebuild that
homepage widget in the build method
we'll start with a scaffold and then as
the body will add a stream builder then
we'll pass it the stream from our
behavior subject so now every time we
add a new value to the behavior subject
this widget will rebuild and one minor
thing that you might have missed is that
we're able to mess this stream builder
deeper in the widget tree and that means
we're repainting less of the UI than we
were in previous examples it's not a big
deal here but it could be if you have a
lot of widgets nested in the scaffold
the next thing we'll do is implement the
Builder function for that we'll just
return our text and that will have a
snapshot of the current count or the
current data from the stream and the
actual etc that data is completely
decoupled from the stream builder which
means we can add it outside of the build
context so it doesn't need to rebuild
whenever the actual value of the stream
changes and another bonus of a stream
builder is that it will automatically
unsubscribe from the stream when the
widget is disposed that means you don't
need to manually cancel streams to avoid
memory leaks this is really nice and
flexible but I'd like to get this
applicable namespace and use it in a way
that's more like a true singleton for
that I'm going to register it with a
library called gedit we'll go ahead and
import that library and then instantiate
get it then we'll go into our main
function and call register singleton
pass in the type counter and then
instantiate the counter now we can use
our counter state in any widget that
requires it this makes the state easier
to mock for integration tests and
guarantees that you won't accidentally
instantiate the counter class more than
once if you're an angular developer I
definitely think you'll like this
pattern but now it's time to move on to
the next strategy the block pattern now
we could implement this
entirely from scratch but I highly
recommend using the flutter block
library under the hood it extends the
inherited widget that we looked at
earlier but it provides a much more
intuitive way to pass state around the
widget tree block is very similar to
redux if you've ever worked with react
it provides a very explicit one-way data
flow that we can break down into three
steps there's an event such as the user
clicking on a button that event gets
dispatched to a block and then it will
reduce the next state and omit it out as
a stream so we can use it in stream
builder just like we did in the previous
example the first thing we'll do is
install block and flutter block then
import them in this file then we'll add
the block provider to the root of the
application the block provider itself
actually extends inherited widget and it
takes a block type which will define in
the next step all descendants of this
widget will be able to access the state
where the data contained inside this
block now the next thing we need to do
is define the actions or the events that
the user can dispatch to the block
we just have one single event with no
data payload we'll define that as the
counter event enum with one value of
increment from there we define the
counter block class and it extends block
which is provided by the library and we
provide it with our counter event you
know that we just created now the job of
the block is to define the initial state
this can be your own class but in our
case it's just an integer that starts at
0 the next thing we do is define a
reducer function called map event to
state it has the current state as its
first argument and the event as its
second argument if you've ever worked
with redux or ng rx this should look
very familiar and you'll know the next
step is to define a switch statement
that will look at the event itself and
then determine how to reduce the next
state based on that event so to
increment a counter we take the current
state and add 1 to it and now we're
ready to build out the actual home page
UI widget so this will just be a
stateless widget and inside its build
method it can access the counter block
which it does by calling block provider
of contexts
along with our counter block type and
that should feel very natural to a
flutter developer because you do the
same thing for media queries and themes
and things like that at this point we
want to rebuild the UI when the state of
the block changes we can do that with a
block builder the block builder is just
like a stream builder but instead of a
stream it takes the block as an argument
then we can access the current state
inside of this function which in our
case is just the integer of the counter
when it comes to changing the state we
don't actually mutate the state directly
like we have in previous examples
instead we dispatch an action to the
block and I really like this approach
because it separates all of our business
logic from the widget which is now only
concerned with rendering the UI and
dispatching actions so it obviously took
a little more code to get to this point
but the block pattern is a solid state
management solution that can pay off in
the long run now I don't know if you've
been keeping count but I promise you ten
different state management solutions so
far we've only covered five but there
are five more that you should definitely
know about before making any big
decisions the godfather of all the state
management stuff is redux which has been
the de facto state management library
from the react world but is also
available on flutter it follows a lot of
the same concepts that we just looked at
in the block pattern but usually you
have a single store provider for the
entire app and then you connect that
store to different widgets where it's
needed if you're brand new to state
management I would probably recommend
going straight to block but if you're
already experienced with redux this is
definitely something you'd want to check
out there's another library that
recently became available in flutter
that also comes from the react world mob
X a poll is a lot of the same principles
as redux and block but provides some
extra abstractions that I think make the
process a little more developer-friendly
and one thing that's cool is that it has
a code gen package that you can use to
eliminate a lot of the boilerplate code
that can be very useful if you want to
apply these powerful state management
patterns but have a small team or maybe
you're just prototyping out some ideas
quickly now mob X read X and block are
all state management libraries that I
would consider a pretty heavy weight
that require a lot of explicit code if
you just want to change some data and
pass it around the widget tree then you
should check out scoped model this is
the state management approach that they
described in the official documentation
and like a lot of the other things we've
looked at it uses an inherited widget to
pass state around the tree but in this
version you don't have to write your own
reducer functions or actions or any
other boilerplate code basically you
just define your data and your mutations
inside of a model then you scope that
model somewhere in the widget tree and
then you have a builder that can rebuild
the UI when that model changes so it's a
relatively simple way to deal with
shared state the next package on this
list is one I haven't actually used yet
but that looks very promising flutter
hooks I have used hooks in react Jas and
they definitely improve productivity and
also code reusability this example from
the docs has a use reducer hook and you
can see that hook sets up a lot of the
things that we'd have to do manually
like the state and the action
dispatching so that's a really nice
alternative to the stateful widget or
some of the other approaches that we
looked at for local
state the last item on this list is one
you might not expect
firebase but a lot of people don't
realize is that firebase is already a
state management system that is way more
advanced than anything you're going to
build it may not be a solution for every
state management need but it can't
handle some of the most advanced aspects
of state management like user
authentication persisting data to it
back-end database remote config file
uploads and the list goes on the
firebase SDK exposes everything as
streams or futures which is exactly what
you want with a reactor framework like
flutter I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if I miss anything
please let me know in the comments and
if you want to support this channel and
get access to even more content consider
becoming a pro member at fire ship IO
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]